today's topic is one of the most famous
stories in statistics
uh it's also about where babies come
from um
i know you know where babies come from
but
there used to be this tale that's what i
grew up with that babies
come from stalks if a child is asking
awkward questions of his or her parents
the parents would say well you know the
stalks
bring the baby in draped from their bill
in a blanket that's where your baby
brother or your baby sister
came from have you figured out where
that came from why stalks were
associated with babies at all
so there's a theory it's something to do
with um stalks being a traditional
symbol of fertility a religious symbol
of fertility and another
theory is that stalks when they go
fishing they're
looking for embryonic life forms in the
water so that is
that is two theories um i don't know i'm
i'm an economist you know i'm not a not
a sort of a
studio of mythology and ritual anyway
anyway to get back to the important
stuff which is
the statistics so stalks deliver babies
this is the old story let me try to
prove that to you
statistically i've got my i've got my
paper here so
and this is just going to be a um
illustrative plotting if you imagine two
axes
and here this is babies per year and
here
we have the number of stalks and if you
just take a a bunch of european
countries and i have actually seen the
data
what you find is turkey if i remember
and this is poland and then
you might have germany here and then
you've got a whole bunch down here
a couple there and it's not the world's
best correlation
but it's it's not the world's worst
correlation
loads down here with not many babies not
many stalks you've got these big
outliers here you've got nothing here
you've got no places
with um loads of babies and no stalks
you've got
no places with loads of stalks and no
babies and you can draw a best fit line
and it goes like that and there is
actually an academic paper
about 20 years ago with the title stalks
deliver babies
p equals 0.008 and without going into
the technical details
you probably know that according to the
conventional standards of statistical
significance that means
this relationship is not a coincidence
there is definitely a
correlation between stalks and babies
now you're probably thinking to yourself
okay so what's the trick
because surprise surprise talks don't
actually deliver babies
um email me if you actually want me to
explain where babies do come from
when i get a reply well maybe
um so so what's going on here
what's going on here is basically as i
said i think this is turkey this is
poland
there's there's monaco there's
luxembourg there's lichtenstein down
here lots and lots of places with very
small
amounts of land there are no stalks and
there are no kids basically and here are
places that are really big
lots of stalks lots of babies and that's
what's going on that's enough
to drive that statistical correlation
the amount of land is the hidden
uh is the hidden factor yes the secret
thing that's driving both
a large population which means a lot of
babies and
it is driving the large number of stalks
because bear in mind i'm not
i didn't say birth rate i'm sure there's
well i expect there's no correlation
for the birth rate what i'm talking
about is the the
number of babies born each year in this
in these countries which is very closely
correlated to the population
so you would also perhaps expect a
correlation with trees
yeah yeah probably number of trees
versus number of babies a year
trees also deliver babies i mean you
could you go in all kinds of places like
this
and there were lots of these um these
spurious correlations
out there actually there's a website
maintained by a guy called tyler
viglen i think called spurious
correlations full of all kinds of fun
stuff like this but
i said at the beginning that this is one
of the most famous stories
in statistics it was made famous by
a fellow called darrell huff and here
for me is where this gets
really interesting so dewell half was a
journalist and in 1954
he published a book with the title how
to lie
with statistics it got a rave review in
the new york times
it became many people say the best
selling book
about statistics ever written and i
loved it
when i was a teenager reading about all
of these
tricks all the different ways you could
be deceived he's got the stalks and
babies in there it's got loads and loads
of great examples
it's got dodgy maps it's got dodgy
graphs it's got
all sorts of great great examples it's a
very funny book
um i'm not the only person who likes it
ben goldacre who wrote
bad science and many other great books
about numbers he
praised darrell half charles whelan who
wrote a book called naked statistics he
said it was an
homage to daryl half there are loads of
fans of drell huff out there this book
is in praise of statistics though this
this book is supposed to be doing a
service
to statistics presumably so that i think
is where
the important question uh lies it
it is loved by nerds but it is not
really in praise of statistics because
what dual half is doing
is in chapter after chapter example
after example he's debunking
dodgy statistics and he just doesn't
have a lot of positive examples
of statistics being used to illuminate
the world
and that's where i start to get a little
bit queasy
because that book was published in 1954
and you know what else happened in 1954
two great statisticians epidemiologists
richard dole and austin bradford hill
provided some of the first solid
evidence that smoking cigarettes
might well give you lung cancer because
the same year two
different visions of what you can do
with statistics darrell huff is saying
it's a bit of a joke it's a bit of fun
i'll tell you the story about the stalks
and the babies
um but don't don't ever take statistics
too seriously because they're just a way
for people to lie to you
austin bradford hill and richard doll
are using this
vital tool to find out the answer to one
of the
key medical questions of the 20th
century
and when you think about it they
couldn't have done that in any other way
than using a
the statistical lens so even to notice
that lung cancer cases were on the
increase and they were
massively you need to be systematically
counting
cases of lung cancer i mean you maybe
there'd be some anecdotes but
you know you need the numbers you need
the data and then to show
compellingly that uh there's there's
evidence of causation
you really need to work hard with the
statistics a lot of people at the time
thought it was something to do with cars
which is not crazy you think about it
between the beginning of the 20th
century and the 1950s
lung cancers on the increase so are cars
loads of cars
maybe it's something in the tarmac maybe
it's uh something you know coming out of
the exhaust
is not a crazy idea but it turns out it
wasn't the cars
it was the cigarettes this is so
important this is such a key fact
understanding that this thing is true
this has
saved literally tens of millions of
lives possibly hundreds of millions of
lives
and you've got to rail half and remember
this the the best-selling book
ever published about statistics saying
don't ever take statistics too seriously
because they're basically
liars will use them to lie to you
there's a twist in this story
because in the 1960s the us senate held
hearings to decide whether cigarette
packets should have warning labels on
them should smokers be warned you know
maybe this is going to kill you
and they got all these expert witnesses
in to discuss the evidence
and one expert witness came in and he
told the senators
look don't worry too much because
there are a lot of funny correlations
out there
let me tell you about stalks and babies
and he sat there and he told the
senators
all about how you could demonstrate this
correlation
between babies and stalks he used a
slightly different example but the same
basic argument
and it's the same with with cigarettes
and lung cancer and the senator who was
chairing the commission said
do you seriously mean to tell me that
there is as as casual a relationship
between smoking and lung cancer
as there is between stalks and babies
and the expert witness says yeah they
seem to me
to be about the same and his name you
may have seen it coming
darrell huff the guy who published
how to lie with statistics he was
actually working on a sequel
which was never published called how to
lie with smoking statistics
so he'd taken this you know this you
know
funny witty skepticism about statistics
in this great little book and he'd
soured it into this
nasty cynicism that everything out there
is fake news you can't believe a single
thing you're told
and he'd then gone to work for the
tobacco lobby who found him to be the
perfect
witness for their case if you'd like
more great stories like this from tim
harford
check out his book how to make the world
add up
this is what it looks like just in case
you need to know the links in the
description
include a chance to get yourself a
signed copy you can also catch tim
talking with matt
over at stand-up maths again links in
all the usual places